In this problem, a laboratory at a water
pollution control plant receives a
sludge feed sample. The sample is placed
into a 10 g sampling dish and weighed.
The scale reads
142.6
g. After drying in an oven, the dish and
dried sample weigh 32.5 g.
The dried sample is then ignited in a
furnace and the final weight of the dish
and remaining ash is 16.48
g. What percent of the sample is
comprised of solids? And of those
solids, what percent are
volatile? So, this is one of those
problems that asks us to find two
different answers before picking one of
the choices below.
Let's solve them one at a
time. I couldn't find key words in the
environmental reference manual that
would help with this problem. Please let
me know in the comments if you find any
useful pages to
reference. So, what we will do first is
simplify the problem statement down to
the most important cases of the sludge
sample. So,
first the wet weight of the sample is as
follows.
We're going to take the 142.6
g and subtract out the weight of the
dish, leaving us with 132.6
g. Next, the sentence about the
oven indicates that this is the
information for the dry sample. So the
dry
sample is
32.5
g minus the weight of the dish to get
22.5
g.
Finally, the sentence about the furnace
provides our information about the ash
and the volatiles. So, the sentence
gives
us the dish and ash being
16.48
g, meaning that the ash alone is
6.48
g. Now that we have solved for these
values, solving our problem is very
easy. Let's start by finding
the percent solids.
The percent of the solids is simply
found by finding the ratio of dry to wet
sample. So since we've already
calculated these, we can just plug them
right in.
22.5
over 132.6.
and our result is going to
be.17 or
17%. So already we can throw
away the first answer and the fourth
answer from our
list. Now if we were looking for the
percent of
volatile, we can calculate this as
follows.
The volatile sample is going to be the
percent that was burned off in the
furnace. The nonvolatile portion is
going to be the part that remained, aka
the ash.
So the way that we can write this up
here is going to be the percent dry that
went into the furnace minus the ash
remaining in the
furnace
over the total weight of the dry going
into the
furnace. So this is going to be
22.5 minus
6.48 over
22.5 and this is going to give
us about
71 or
71%. Which we can see over here is our
second answer.
So this problem is very simple if you
can pull out the relevant information
you need for this problem and not get
tripped up and accidentally calculate
the wrong
thing. For example, if you calculated A
correctly but then calculated for the
nonvolatile in
B, you could end up with the third
answer here.
Similarly, if you
calculated a
incorrectly by dividing the weight of
the dry dish by the weight of the wet
dish, you would have found an answer
closer to
23%. And selected either the first or
the fourth answer. So, just getting
familiar with exactly what it is you're
supposed to solve for and doing this
repetitively should help you to gain
more familiarity with how to approach
these questions if you can't find any
help in the reference
manual. And that's it.